Bye-bye.
Hi, hi.
Hello.
I am Striggler diabo.
He was quite dangerous.
Were you nervous?
Oh, not the ad.
Oh, not the super loud game.
Oh, what the hell?
I think, did Alderman update or something?
Because everything's, like, really weird.
Ooh, what's happening?
I'm gonna put you in the litter box.
Let me turn down the sound volume a little bit more.
I don't know why the game is suddenly full-screen and not borderless windowed.
I think the game might have updated.
Alderman Jump Scare.
Ooh, Shrieken Witch.
I'm still a cat.
I forgot about that.
I still haven't eaten my Taco Bell yet.
Can I please?
Why is OBS doing this to me?
Please let me...
It's just not letting...
I can't make the window any smaller on OBS.
Usually I can make it smaller.
It's just, like, nope.
Hi.
It's a good look.
You guys, like...
You guys, like, kitty-kitty-sheebie?
Kibbie?
You can call me Kibbie.
Hi, Mari.
Kibbie.
I'm Kibbie.
Very distant cousin.
It's a very cute outfit, though.
Like, hold on.
I'll show you guys.
It's a very...
Like, look how cute it is.
It's a very cute outfit.
And I can beat you up.
I love booth outfits.
They're so fun.
Keep jiggling.
But...
And...
I don't know if there's any other toggles for this.
There's...
Can I take off the bat?
What do you mean?
There's a little bunny on my hip, too.
Which is funny, because it says milk.
So you think I'd be, like, a cat on the hip?
I like the palette.
Go back the handout.
Oops, sorry.
Give me your money.
What?
I'm not even gonna read that out loud.
The...how are the toggles?
I haven't eaten them yet.
I haven't even opened the bag.
You're drawing a what in my...
No, put it away.
Put it away.
I have some potatoes.
What is this?
I've never had the potatoes.
Oh, boomies got the zoomies.
Oh.
He just slammed into the window.
Kibby.
He also gave me nachos for free.
I didn't...oh wait, no, that was part of the thing.
Can I dip the nachos in the potatoes?
I never had these before.
I don't really eat Taco Bell.
Oh, I broke the nacho.
What's new?
Mmm!
They're not pretty good.
Have money, Minko?
That sounds really interesting.
Do you feel the suggestion for that game?
No, I didn't get cinnamon twists.
I don't like those. They're gross.
I had them before. I didn't like them.
I keep breaking the chip. I can't even pick it up.
Good night.
Night night.
Forever eating on stream.
Baja Blast is spicy but has no flavor.
It's like soda water.
I got the cantina meal.
So it's a cantina burrito with a cantina taco.
Hi!
They are nasty.
I can't.
Let's see if this is good.
I'm kind of flat.
Mmm!
This is very good.
Want some help?
This is very tasty.
I'm like pleasantly surprised.
Mmm!
There's no rice in it that I can see.
I usually get the steak chalupa.
I like the chicken chalupa.
I don't know. I haven't had that in years though.
I don't think they ever brought it back, did they?
I don't know.
The chicken.
It's like made out of chicken.
I thought that was really tasty.
You guys really like my outfit, huh?
You guys are going crazy.
Chalupas are bangers.
I like the breading.
I like soft tacos.
I don't really like hard tacos.
I just end up choking and almost dying.
I'm about to enter the shadowkeep.
Well,
I've already broken Micola's charm.
I'm just going back and I'm getting the ice perfume bottle thingy
so I can fight Mesmer.
The food is actually making me feel better.
Oh, my dams.
She literally drew a dick in my hand, guys.
I can't stop giggling at it. It looks so silly.
I don't know.
Yeah, we know.
It's something.
Oh, Miwa sending me nice messages.
Hold on, I need a message from Miwa
because now I'm just checking all my discord messages.
Miwa is very sweet.
She's like, I'm sorry for the delay, for the role play.
And I'm like, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it, sweetheart.
It takes time.
Um,
I don't know.
I had a really good day today.
Today was a really good day.
Well, it wasn't, it wasn't a good day
because of my ISP.
And because I threw up this morning
and I didn't get any sleep.
Excuse me, but my friends just made it a lot better
and you guys made it a lot better.
I'll be honest with you.
Hi.
Hello.
Um,
okay.
You definitely have to go to the bathroom for you.
I feel like, hold on.
Let me, I see take my kitty to the litter box.
You're gonna hear her squeak.
She's on my desk, by the way.
I have a disabled cat.
I just don't work.
I have to carry her around with everybody.
Everybody gets the gist.
Yeah.
Here.
Let's do it in the litter box.
There you go.
Okay.
Poop to your heart's content.
Via poops and they're like human size, by the way.
Her shits are bigger than mine
because her body moves so slow to like
do it.
Via, don't eat the
wait, leave her alone.
She's trying to do shit.
I lit, hold on.
I literally throw her stuff in the toilet.
Ah!
What is happening?
Is this what you want?
Is this what you're into?
She's taking care of my disabled cat.
She's taking a poo and she's trying to eat litter.
Can you stop?
She like tries to chew
on the um
and play with the like
litter pellets and it's like really funny to me.
Damn girl, that's huge.
I have some gloves next to my desk
that I usually put on so I'm going to do that right now
and then I'll wash my hands.
Shit, girl.
Oh my god, that's like
Yeah, I knew you had to use the bathroom.
I brought you earlier before I started stream.
I don't know why.
Holy
Her face when she's pooping is funny.
My god.
I've had the urge so many times
to take a picture
to show you guys.
Yeah, I know. I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to move you out of the way so I can help you.
Damn girl.
That shit stinks.
What?
I'm dying.
Are you still shitting?
Are you done?
I definitely have to give you a bath tomorrow
because
you're still pushing. I can see it on your face.
Boomi, leave her alone.
She doesn't need to be bothered when she's pooping.
I have shit all over my hands.
You might be wondering, Sheevie,
how the heck can you eat after this?
I'm hungry. I haven't eaten all day.
And honestly, I'm so used to taking care of Fia
that I'm just like whatever.
It's like...
I don't know what to do with my hands.
I've got too much shit all over them.
I'm not going to wash them in the sink.
Goring gloves.
Don't worry.
All right.
Okay.
Okay, I still have to clean her.
I'm so sorry.
Hello, Miss.
Oh, I can't put you back on the bed
because you have to go back.
You have to go in the deep end.
You stink, girl.
I'm going to die.
I want to see what you guys are saying in the chat.
I can't tell.
I'm embarrassed.
It's a lot of love.
I have to find that clip
because I literally, there's a clip of me
in my PL
and I'm like, sorry guys, hold on.
My cat's shitting and I have to hold her up.
Hi, ma'am.
Hi, Miss.
Where are your wipes?
Where did your wipes go?
Where did I put them?
Hello?
Boomi, can you stop trying to attack my feet
when I'm trying to take care of your sister?
Thanks.
What are you...
What are you doing, dude?
He's like waiting to pounce on me.
Where I need a trash bag.
Trash bag.
I know.
When you come over here for like,
you don't get something.
Hello, ma'am.
He is patiently waiting for me to wipe her ass.
Tomagotchi's are a different story.
Oh, no, I'm almost out of wipes.
I'm going to use these last ones.
But I have extra wipes.
They're just not...
specifically for cats.
Let me wipe your butt with that tissue first, ma'am.
You're going to hear Fia squeak
because obviously I don't think anybody likes
their butt being wiped.
Unless you're a baby.
Even then. Or you have a fetish for that.
I don't know.
Hi, Shibi. How's it going?
I'm wiping my cat's ass because she just shit.
So it's comfortable.
Hi.
Hi, Steven.
Yeah, I'm going to wipe your stinky gross butt.
That's a lot more than I bargained for.
You get some more tissues.
Uh, I should go.
Boomi, get your head out, please.
He's like, I would like to smell version.
Thank you very much.
Hi, if you're new here and you're like,
I just came to watch a cute cat girl play Ellen Ring.
I'm sorry, I have a disabled cat
and I need to take care of her first and foremost.
Because it's a gorilla.
I'm like, whatever.
You guys can listen to me do it
because the bod's probably going to be gone anyways.
Because I just delete a lot of gorillas.
Hi.
I'm sorry.
I know you don't like this, Lily.
What?
Why are you looking at me like that?
She's like, you are violating me, mother.
You can't lick your own ass, so
this is the only option we have.
Alright, so
I'm going to pick you up and I'm actually going to take you out of the mailbox.
Yeah.
Oh, you can hold yourself up pretty good.
I'm impressed.
You can hold up her front and half.
Alright, I'm going to wipe your bum.
I am a mother.
First and foremost.
Why does madam hate gorillas?
What?
Do you want me to keep this up?
I don't know if anybody wants to hear me just like
talking about taking care of my cat.
I don't know.
Poor bod game.
Okay, fine. I'll keep the bod up.
I don't think my content is good enough
to keep up a lot of time.
And it's a gorilla.
It's not even scheduled.
Hi.
She sounds like she's saying no.
Oh, she growling.
Sorry, ma'am.
You're a rear.
He's retaking care of
angry baby.
Mother, stop touching my ass.
Well, I have to.
I'm sorry.
It's entertaining shit.
Pun intended.
My gorillas are comfy.
You think, is this comfy?
Is this comfy for you?
Are you extremely comfy
hearing me talk about
how I'm taking care of my disabled cat
and wiping her ass?
Does that get you going?
Shut up, Mari.
Yeah?
Alright, yeah.
She's looking at me like I just killed her dog.
Are you mad at me?
No, don't be mad at me.
Please.
You literally have poop on you.
I'm trying to help.
Yeah, you're definitely
getting a bath tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're getting a bath.
But you've been through a lot of stress,
so I'm not going to do it to you right now.
Are you stink?
You're a poopy baby.
You have a poopy baby butt.
Pooey, what are you doing?
I'm going to pick you up.
Why are you screaming?
You just made me get poop on my arm,
so thanks for that.
Now she's a little bit more global,
so she's hard to control.
I want to let you form
your head to your toes,
and I want to...
You feel better now,
because you pooped?
Loomie, go like
be useful and lick your ass or something.
I don't know.
I'm going to wash my hands.
I have some.
Hands washed.
Baby put to bed.
I'm going to wrap her up in a little blanket here.
You want a blanket?
I'm sorry for, you know,
the final move
without me.
What is that?
There you go.
Now you're all tucked in
and snug into a bugger rug.
But you're getting your bath tomorrow.
I need to let a candle cause
God damn.
All right.
What about we were playing Elden Ring, right?
I need a fork.
I need a fork for my potatoes.
I accidentally
kind of
twisted my ankle
when I was going down the stairs.
I stepped down on my ankle
when I was going down the stairs
because I didn't take the elevator.
I took it back up though,
because I wasn't even...
I'm like, ow.
You did say your child's mommy issues.
If you were
in pain,
if you were a little vegetable,
if you were paralyzed,
I'd take care of you the same way.
No.
They don't hiss at each other.
They only will hiss at each other
if one boomy's being annoying
like he is right now, he just hopped on my desk.
Um...
Hey!
Don't try to take the fucking nacho.
Um...
He's trying to have my fucking potatoes!
And
if they come back from the vet
and they smell weird, then
Reina especially, Reina hates the vet
and she hates the smell of the vet.
Did they give me an extra taco?
Can you
go over there, sir?
I don't know if boomy could eat any of these.
I don't know if they...
They probably have garlic and stuff.
Boomy, you want a little cheese?
Actually...
Well, you know what? You don't deserve it anyways.
You were an absolute piece of shit
this morning.
Sorry, that's him skating in the background.
Yep.
It's zoomie time.
You know those pictures I posted of them
snuggling
and like Fiya like
grooming him and stuff?
Because they were grooming each other.
And I was like, oh nice!
Because Fiya can't really groom herself.
I have to give her a bath or I have to wipe her down.
This little like
anti-dander wipes
and like spray her and like kind of do like
waterless shampoo.
Oh my god, boomy.
He's making such funny noises when he's running around.
And I was like, oh nice!
And they haven't snuggled like that in a bit.
And then I leave and I come back
and Fiya's fucking screaming because
he has her by the throat.
And I'm like, boomy!
Fiya was like, you know how Fiya was like
meowing like you heard her?
Like even more like, ahhhh!
And I'm like, oh my god!
I went, I got up to go
what was I doing? I went to the closet
to, I think
to change my shirt because I like
I don't know if I spilled something on it.
I can't remember.
And he's here for Fiya's
screaming.
And I'm like, oh my god, boomy!
You're being so good.
And then Reina was yelling at me.
Boomy keeps eating her food.
And so Reina comes
like
Reina will come over to me, yell
and I'm like, what?
And I look over and Boomy's eating out of both
of the cat dishes.
And Reina tells on him.
And so I have to go
and um
put Boomy in another room
so Reina can eat.
This has been happening for the last like two days.
Why would I film
my cat
chewing on my other cat's neck? I know
I'm not gonna do that. I'm not gonna record
my cat's enacting violence.
Like I recorded Boomy and Fiya when Fiya
was able-bodied
and they were playing with each other.
Hello.
My hair Reina yell
cause I think Boomy took her food again.
Cause I fed her and then I went
downstairs to get my food.
Did I accidentally order steak?
I don't think I'm gonna finish this.
But I'd rather have the steak chalupa
than the taco.
Cause I just clicked on my order from last time
which was like a couple months ago.
And so I must have
um
had his chalupa with it.
Bonus!
Boomy, I apologize.
Yeah, honestly
he can mess with me.
He just can't mess with Fiya.
That's like not cool.
If I could
please open Elden Ring.
Where had a cord?
Well the reason why me
I was taking so long
my Taco Bell's cold now but it's fine.
The reason I was taking so long
for me and Yana's stream
was because
I woke up late.
I woke up at like 7.30
at like 7.20
and I was like shit.
And so I quickly
had to throw everything together.
And set up everything.
Game's a bit loud.
Your mom's a bit loud
when I rammed her last night.
I don't know.
Um
but yeah
Eepie
everybody
cry.
You guys are funny.
Oh
You know I don't usually like that
like type of cheese but
sour cream they got pretty good.
Yeah I was just improv. It was really funny though.
It was Elden Yana's idea.
I liked it a lot.
Because I was going to like
actually try to teach her ASMR
and like try to do a better job than I did with Para.
But
we decided to go in a Mimi direction.
What the heck did I drink?
I drank leftover dry ice water
that's been sitting in a cup.
I meant to just like gurgle on it
but then it tasted so bad.
That's why I gagged.
I was like that one meme
with Eric Andre
where I just shoot you over a gun.
Mm-hmm
Yeah it was fun.
It seemed like a lot of everybody was entertained.
I haven't checked if my tomagachi is dead.
I
feel like a tomagachi has like a microphone
or
some sort of motion detector
because sometimes when I move past it it'll wake up
and it kind of freaks me out
because it'll be like sheebie.
Oh my god it turned into the fucking cactus again.
Oh my god.
Just die. Just die. Just die.
Just die you fool.
Just die.
I don't know if you heard Reino just hissing at Boomi.
Boomi, she doesn't want to play with you.
Boomi, come here.
Come here.
Don't stare at me like that.
You're some boy.
Why are you
posting up like that for?
Okay whatever.
I don't know.
I'm not telling what the good news is.
I can't tell you. It's not my place to say.
Okay.
They'll find out in another couple months
or whatever.
It's a secret.
Well I'm just saying a couple months because I'm just
I don't know how long it's going to take.
No.
There's no NDA.
What? I do it for a sheebie snack?
What's a sheebie snack?
What would be a sheebie snack?
Hold on. Let me make myself smaller.
I'll be a cat for the remainder
of the stream I suppose.
Since you got I'm like too lazy.
I was going to throw a blanket on and everything
but I'm too lazy.
You know what's really funny?
Me
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's happening here?
What's going on?
Uncrustables?
Oh my god. I have uncrustables.
A while ago. I actually just remember
they're in my freezer right now. Thanks guys.
I literally cannot recall
why I forgot those were in there.
What am I going to say?
I forget.
I don't want to say where are my glasses
but they're on my head.
I meant to say where are my headphones.
Oh my god.
Post meal snack?
I know. My tummy does not have enough room
for an uncrustable right now.
I still have a taco next to me
and I'm like I can eat it
and I'm like I will puke if I try to consume
maybe in like an hour I'll be able to eat it.
It'll be cold by then
but that's fine.
Good volume. Thank you.
Somebody remind me
to
turn off the candle.
Blow out the candle in like
15 minutes.
Your tortilla chips are pretty good.
I won't lie to you some.
I got 99 problems
and a bad tortilla chip ain't one.
Also every day when my parents
are gone this week
I have to go to my mom's house
and water her plants
in the morning so after I feed Fia
I have to go to my parents house
and I'm like oh
my mom has a big garden
in the front and the back
Did you get the keys to their place?
My mom gave me a backup
because my mom always has backups.
No, I still don't have my keys by the way.
I saw the maintenance guy.
I was scared to talk to him because he's the one
that saw my sex toys, well he didn't see my sex toys
but he saw the
door frame thing that I had
from some like
sex toy website
that said like don't
disturb my masturbating and I'm like fuck
I left that out and I left the
lush out as well.
It was the same maintenance guy
so I didn't really want to talk to him
and be like hey did you hear about the keys?
Yeah does anybody remember that?
Them just coming into my apartment
and me being too scared to be like
wait this wasn't scheduled
and I'm just like changing all my filters
and then going into my room and seeing all my
inappropriate things.
Yeah they saw the crop as well.
Yeah that was the same one that like giggled at me.
That was like oh so they all know that I'm like
they're like they probably think I'm like
this crazy oldie fans person.
What was I doing here?
This was the deeper
I just put the key in.
Okay this is where
I don't know why we're going this way.
I'm kind of scared.
I hear a lot of moaning.
I hear it sounds like
like a massive orgy.
Yeah I know I'm getting the frost.
Are they so like where are they down here?
What the fuck?
Oh there's one of those things over there.
Um...
It's not letting me lock on them though.
They're just, they're just peeking.
Is there anything over here?
Another hole?
Yeah.
Diagro please. What are you doing?
Just fucking running away.
What's this hole?
I'm just gonna, why do they keep running back and forth?
I'm just gonna crouch so maybe it'll continue to Diagro.
Yeah it's like waiting to like run out
and like grab me and I'm just not there.
In a room after being jumped by jar people.
So I just literally just have to keep
digging around until I find them.
I'm assuming right?
Oh my god that guy, I'm waiting.
Let's say I have a vagina on its back.
I'm waiting for it to
just fucking run over here.
It looks like it's like I'm gonna get you.
Aw you're not there.
Have a good night. Bye.
Oh hi Rekuma.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
You're so sweet.
I hope you're having a good day, evening,
morning, night, afternoon.
I can't get up.
Hello? Okay I just have to jump then.
Um, alright.
Why did you yell?
Wait why do I only have 5 flasks?
And since when was I plus 9?
I was plus 8.
I'm a little confused.
If you got gifted make sure you say thank you.
That's quite odd.
Aw.
Aw I'll put you out of your misery.
You too.
Found it. Alright let's go.
I'm not going in here. No thanks.
I'm good.
Amazing.
Really cool. Really nice being here.
Um.
I got what I came here for.
So...
Want me to finish the dungeon?
Nah. Nah I'm good.
Thanks though.
Maybe next time.
Perhaps another time.
Perhaps another never.
Yeah I'm good.
I know there's a lot of more spooky stuff in this game
than the last one.
That was so loud.
Since when do I have plus 9?
I just...
I thought I was plus 8.
Since forever?
Oh okay.
I was thinking...
I probably should get more
flasks.
But...
It'll be such a bitch
to try to get all those golden seeds.
Thank you.
Um.
Wait why did I mark that?
I don't know.
Oh wait.
What was that for?
I was to find the opening.
You liked me Niana?
It was honestly...
It made my day so much better to hang out with her again.
I missed her a lot.
And it really warmed my heart.
And she was like,
I love you and I miss you so much.
And I was like, oh my god.
I'm about to cry in this call Niana.
She's so sweet.
She's planning on
getting a surgery for her cat.
Because her cat is a little sick.
I didn't actually ask the specifics of it.
But I want to help her out with that.
Um.
So I'm...
If she has a donut on or anything,
I'm probably going to
boost it and donate myself.
Because again, as someone who has a sickly cat,
it sucks.
Yeah.
I had no idea you two knew each other.
Yeah, my PL, we hung out.
I bet the pow world stream on her side
is still a high boomy.
What's going on? Can I help you?
You almost stepped in the cheese.
Sorry, he's controlling my character.
Can you
get off the spacebar?
Thanks.
Hey, can you move your butt?
Your butt's in the way.
Your stinky butt.
Mister, please.
At least it's cleaner than Fia's.
Sir?
You can't have...
Do you want a chip? Is that what you want?
You can lick the chip.
Haha.
You may lick the chip.
He's giving it little licks and nibbles.
It's quite adorable.
Boomy's actually very gentle when he takes food from my hand.
Sorry, he's sitting on my spacebar.
So he's making me jump.
Oh,
you can take a little bite.
You can have a little bite.
Go on.
Boomy, you can't just bite it.
You have to crunch it.
You can have a little crunch.
Okay, you're actually quite adorable right now.
Good boy, do you like it?
Did you hear him crunch it?
Do you like the tortilla chip?
I have to, like, monitor him while he eats this
because I don't want him to choke on anything.
Here, you have a little...
have a little piece.
You're very cute when you want to be.
Okay, well, are you done with this?
You seem to be distracted by whatever is...
there's nothing over there, but that's fine.
He's literally just taking it in between his teeth
and going
and then just, like, licking it
and then giving it back to me.
Here.
I'm assuming you just want the salt.
Sorry, again, he's sitting on my spacebar.
And now he's holding my hand.
He took his paw and he placed it on my hand
and he licked the chip
and he just jumped away.
All right, bye.
If there's a sixth member of Gen 1...
No, Niana will never be an
vealer.
I...
she is...
if I associate...
if I collab with someone,
please don't assume they're going to be in the next gen
or, like, whatever,
and make some of them uncomfortable
because they don't do that...
the content that we do, you know?
Niana, although she's, like,
not exactly say so,
she doesn't do 18 plus content
and I wouldn't want her to feel like
she's, like, being lumped in
with something that she doesn't do, you know?
Oh, yeah, no, I'm not...
I'm just saying it to you, like, a couple people
have already, like, we're saying in the chat
she needs to be a part of vealer.
Honestly, it's like, she said that
she thought it was funny and that she's
flattered and everything, but
how does this work?
Never had this before.
Where is it? Where are the perfume bottles?
Causes frost buildup.
Yeah, interesting.
Oh, yeah, I have the thing that
re-does my F.P., by the way,
which is pretty nifty.
Sorry, I want to switch it to this hand.
Yeah, interesting.
Oh, yeah, I have the thing that re-does
my F.P., by the way,
which is pretty nifty.
Sorry, I want to switch it to this hand.
The perfume bottles are quite pretty.
I just want to see...
Oh, that's just a kick.
Oh, okay, so those have a heavy...
What the fuck is in my hand? Oh, it's, like,
interesting.
What if I do...
It's weird that
I don't do, like, some other...
Like, I'm just... Why am I kicking?
Oh, yeah, yeah, of course.
Yeah, no.
Yeah, I do want a Latina and Gen 2.
100% I do.
But Neon is not the person
I had in mind because I know how she...
how she is.
Trust me, if she was like...
If she turned around, she was like, actually,
I would be like...
I'd be like, Poggers, please.
Nepoire, this will be a stat.
Default Ash... Wait, can I change the Ash?
Why is that the Ash?
Wait, I can two-hand it?
Holy shit.
Do I ever run out?
Do I ever run out of frost?
No?
You'd think this would be, like, F.P. related.
That's very interesting.
The good Ash is in a camp?
I'm camp.
What Ash?
Tell me, I'll go there.
I'm a cat.
And I dance, dance, dance, dance, dance.
Cat. I'm a kitty cat.
Hold on, I'm going to balance the...
I want to balance the...
a controller on my boobies.
It's funny, the controller is called Ice Controller.
I need...
Sweet.
Perfect.
Can I have, like, some hands?
Do I have any hands?
No.
I only have hands that, like...
You know what I should do?
I should get my own controller made.
I should probably commission that.
I should probably get that for myself as a little Christmas gift.
Sorry, I'm looking at a funny message.
Because Marcy posted the Gamer Sup's...
art in our...
in, like, Discord.
And she's like, she me dies!
Me!
And then Strati's like, she's not tan!
Because it was too...
It was already in the works.
So it's kind of funny.
My tummy is growling.
Okay, let me pull that back up.
Oh, the candle, thank you guys.
Okay, where is...
Can we loot it from a flying scrub on the eastern side of the large camp with a Shadowkeep?
Is it...
Eastern side of the large...
Okay, is it within Shadowkeep or...?
Hi, who do you have?
What?
What are you thinking?
What's in water?
Jamawa?
I don't think it's water.
I'm not sure I can share it.
I need the badge for the baby.
Okay. Oh my god, I'm so full from this talk, this room.
Where did Romeo go? He's suspiciously quiet.
Where did he go?
Where's Marina?
Where are my traps?
Where is he?
What are you doing?
What do you do?
Why is that your spot now?
Are you happy about your chin?
Can I take you up?
Can I take you up by the house?
Oh, yes, please.
Yes, please.
You're welcome.
Don't be.
So I have the...
You know that cart you guys got me?
Thank you so much, by the way, for the cart.
It's like that I use for my groceries.
I brought it...
I used it to bring down some trash.
And he just like, like, sleep under it.
I don't know why.
Sorry, I just saw what you guys were staring at.
You got your tub.
Oh, thank you, no one's special.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, no, so it's like, it's on wheels.
And he just goes under the cart
and lays under there for some reason.
And Rena likes to lay inside of it
when I have it out
and not fold it up.
How was my tummy drinking feeling?
It was rumbly,
but it's fine now.
It looks like Rui's playing Black Myth Wukong.
Oh, now I'll be able to play Black Myth Wukong.
I should have put that on the schedule for next week.
I'll do it the week after.
I also have some other good news.
I might be collabing
with a special coddlefish
sooner than I thought.
I'm gonna go monkey.
Yeah, I've been like,
I've been like, Strani, why haven't we hung out yet?
Like we talk like literally every day,
but we still haven't like,
by the way,
Strani makes like her plans like two months in advance.
I'm not like, I'll look at the schedule
and I'm like, why is she all the way out to November?
Um...
Yes, it is an FPS co-op game.
And I believe
that you all will be able to participate
as well.
Wait, is it outside the keep?
I can't remember what you guys said.
Or like south, do you mean like south,
like inside of it?
Why don't I just...
It's not overwatch.
Hello?
It's a fucking
sheep ghost.
Oh...
South of the keep is outside?
Well, maybe your south of the keep, okay?
How about that?
Wait, let's check if I already grabbed it.
Because I'll surprise myself
and I might have...
Because I've already been through the camp, I think.
Um...
Let's click on this one.
Uh-huh, I already have that.
Wait, is that what we were talking about?
Oh no, we're talking about an actual war.
An idiot.
Um...
Let's go.
No...
I'm sorry.
That shit of war, she be...
Yeah, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Rolling sparks?
Is he weak against lightning?
You said south of the camp.
So am I just gonna run around?
I think I actually almost grabbed it before.
Ow.
And I just
ended up not doing so.
Sorry, there's a fire golem right there.
Trying to be discreet.
Being extremely discreet.
Being extremely demure.
I don't understand the demure meme.
I'm sorry, it's like not funny at all to me.
I'll say it, because...
You know...
Of course, I'm gonna hop on trends that have nothing to do with me, but...
Up a few stories east.
Oh, sorry. Oh, sorry.
I might die.
This guy's gonna just fucking smack me in the back.
Can I...
Excuse me, excuse me!
Oh, he took me out.
Yeah, I'm like, they don't even use the word correctly.
That's not what demure means.
Demure.
That's not what it means.
I like it's so funny.
I guess I'm not hip with the kids.
I honestly, like, I used to be super hip
because I used to be on TikTok all the time,
but I just don't really go on TikTok
because I'm too busy nowadays.
And I'd rather just watch
Elden Ring lore videos.
And just lore videos in general.
Um...
Can I, like, jump on top of the tents?
That would be making things a lot easier to navigate.
He said east.
East.
He's so big.
How does anybody even kill it?
Don't they have, like, a million HP or something ridiculous?
Oh, fuck!
I didn't think you'd be able to fucking reach me!
Hello?
Your range is insane, brother.
They're easy to kill?
What do you mean?
I need some kind of weapon equips?
I don't really care.
I'm just trying to get the fucking thing.
My cat is freaking out
and I can't turn and look
because I don't want to get fucking shanked.
I swear, I saw something in a tent
and I bet that was it.
Don't hit me.
It's not very nice. Is this it?
No. It's fucking Ember of Mesma.
Mesma kid.
They die into repulse?
Really?
Oh, interesting.
Alrighty.
Oh, is this it?
No?
Maybe? I don't fucking know.
I'm stuck.
I might be stuck in here.
Oh!
Holy fuck!
I'm getting five guide.
Jesus.
Boomi, what are you skating about?
I know Reina is hiding in my closet right now.
Boomi, did you just scare yourself?
Is your tail on a puff?
Yes.
What's the matter?
Why are you staring at me like you've never seen me before?
Ah!
I don't know if you just heard him run at me going
grrrrrrr.
What?
You're in a goofy mood, huh?
You just want to play, huh?
I would play with you, but I don't know where
your thing went.
I usually give him
a little...
not the spring.
It's like a little cat toy wand.
I don't know where the toy wand went.
Are you eating a chip off the ground?
Yeah, that's the one that you broke.
He's really just eating a chip off the ground.
Are you happy and proud of yourself?
Please don't choke on it.
It's a small piece though, so you should be fine.
How you doing?
Did you enjoy your chip?
Huh?
I wish you gave kisses like Fia.
Boomi, if there's nothing, no.
Boomi is scared of a lot of things, actually.
I can literally just look at him
and he'll freak out.
Or I will, like, move a certain way
he'll freak out. If he hears a noise, he'll freak out.
If he thinks he sees something, he'll freak out.
I had my feet up on my desk
under my blanket
and he hopped up on my desk and almost fucking
gave himself a heart attack because he didn't know what my feet were.
And under the blanket.
And he, like,
was creeping up to them.
And I'm like, dude, and so then I took the blanket off my feet
and he was like, ah, okay.
They're just feet.
I'm like, why?
He definitely has anxiety
and it makes me sad
because he used to not be like this
until
that time when my fire alarms
kept going off because my stupid
previous apartment people
there's nothing in there.
And, um,
is this a major...
Oh, what?
I'm a little confused here.
Oh!
I didn't think he could walk
that far.
What am I stuck on? A tree?
Achoo!
They're so cool.
That's such an interesting...
They have one of my favorite boss designs.
They have one of my favorite
character designs.
Are these ever going to stop?
Or...
Okay, he's over there. At least they move slow.
Thank you.
No, he is on unhealthy skepticism.
I'm debating whether or not
to, like, start giving, like,
getting him diagnosed with something
like, he just is so high
strong sometimes and it makes me sad
because he'll freak out
and, like, I'll open a trash bag
and he'll, like, throw
himself into the closet
behind my dryer because he's so scared
of the sound that a trash bag
makes when you ruffle it
just a little bit.
Like, it triggers him.
Or if he hears a beeping noise, it triggers him.
Um...
I don't
know where this thing is.
Huh.
Sorry, boys.
Sorry. Can I jump?
Oh, I can.
Yeah.
This is what I'm talking about.
Ow.
This is not what I'm talking about.
Is he gonna shoot me?
Haha, you missed.
You buffoon.
Oh, damn it, Torrent.
Damn it, Torrent.
Thank you.
Can you hit me?
I think you can.
Probably.
Uh, there's only a flesh wound.
Ha ha ha.
Flying through the east side of camp.
I'm on the east side.
Oh, flying scarab.
I haven't seen a flying scarab.
Immy raid.
Hi, little sis.
Hi, pin pals.
I hope you guys had a good member stream.
You guys have had an eventful night, huh?
Hi, hello.
We're just playing some Elden Ring,
and I'm trying to avoid getting burnt to death.
And I'm trying to find a bug.
Feel free to stick around
if you want, if you need to go to sleep.
Totally understandable.
We're just big chilling right now.
That was a good night. I'm glad.
Very eventful.
I saw.
But a little bit that I was in there.
I was very, I was very abused.
It's funny to like, be there on the other side,
like part of the audience I realize.
Just like how everybody speaks.
Where the frick is this scarab?
Bro, stop coming at me like that.
I'm going to have to search.
I'm wondering if it already disappeared.
I might have to like,
actually look up a video tutorial.
Immy raid.
Hi.
You guys, there's a lot of raiders.
Just look at the map.
What do you mean? Just look at the map.
The map is not going to tell me where a scarab is.
Oh my god, these fucking dudes.
I don't know.
Oh, there's a bear. Hold on.
I'm also a cat for some reason.
Don't worry about the fact that I'm a cat.
Just, I swear I'm not,
I'm just dressing up.
Oh my god, the bear is on my booty cheeks.
The wiki map.
Oh.
That's true.
Hold on, I need to run away.
What's that?
Ooh.
Oh, it's Ember.
Interesting.
Okay, am I de-aggeroed?
I'm just going to pop over here real quick
in your safety.
I'm a cunny.
I'm a cat bunny. I'm a cunny.
Finally, what I've always wanted.
I'm just like the other girls.
Maybe I can apply for that
university that I see
was followed by.
Outfit's really cute.
It is really cute.
I'll show you more of it.
It's a very cute elf. Ignore that.
That's on my chest.
It's very nice.
It's very cute. I like being able to hit people
with the bat.
It's really nifty.
It's funny that I can hold out my hand
and be like, give me your money.
Thirsty for some reason?
I wonder why.
Okay, where...
Where does that ash called, you guys said?
Shondo approves.
Oh my god, Shondo's new like Bimbo
outfit. I'm like, oh my god,
she's literally me.
Like, that's so funny.
But...
Oh my god, I'm getting like...
I don't know why I'm getting the sniffles.
Do you watch
Zuley the Witch? They do a lot of model
close-ups. I do not.
Sorry, I'm scrolling up the chat.
I can't find it.
You guys said the name.
Rolling Sparks.
Rolling Sparks, rolling in the
D.
In me, if you're still here,
I hope that you have the best sleep
from all your nuts that
you've cracked.
Alden Ring
Location.
Make sure
you guys, you know,
hydrate, pee afterwards.
I know it can be, you know.
You know.
Peeing as they speak.
Oh my god, yes, queen.
Stupid ads.
Oh, by the way, I'm watching a video.
Please don't freak out, there's a male voice.
I will choke you.
Oh, okay, that's interesting.
It literally was, I was right near it,
but I feel like it disappeared
because it's literally
up here.
And I was up there at one point.
Okay, let me go
close that out.
I think that's right.
Shut up, dude.
Oh, it's like super up high.
That's probably why I didn't see it
because it's literally up high.
I could just use the interactive map.
Yeah, but sometimes I need a visual.
Guys, I'm a visual learner.
I need to quit out and reload.
Okay, I can't just go to a different site.
Well, we'll find out.
I don't...
I could be completely wrong
and it could...
I freaked out.
I'm sorry, it choked me.
I can't see, I'm choking you.
Anyways, let's just head over there.
Map service.
No, I need like a 3D...
You know, using Google Maps,
I will look out at the actual
like 3D rendering
and like the road view
because I literally need
to see it.
I can't just see like top down.
That's why I sucked at playing Diablo
because it was like a weird...
It's a weird perspective for me
that I just can't handle.
Oh, there it is. I can see it.
I can literally see it.
It's right above my head if you look up.
All right, that's fine.
I just have to loop around.
Wait, how do I...
How the fuck do I get up there?
How did I get up there before?
Oh...
Oh, then you got the perfumers
right here, perfume and shit.
I don't know how I'm supposed
to get that down.
I don't have anything to throw at it.
Fuck off, lady!
Okay.
Wait, don't leave.
I need to...
I need to get off my damn horse. Where is it?
No, don't leave, don't leave, don't leave.
No, don't leave! Don't leave!
Don't leave!
What is this?
I'm sorry.
Panic zooming in.
I thought if I had
the sword out, I could still...
but that's not how that works.
Ow, I just poked my own eye.
You're lucky you're adorable.
Imagine if I wasn't.
Oh, what the fuck?
Why did Otto save here?
I need to be on my horse.
Okay, alright.
I need to be well prepared.
I do have magic, you're right.
I don't know why I was so
mentally inept for a bit.
Listen, it is
almost 2 am.
No, not the fucking dog.
Fuck you, dog.
No, dog, please!
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna kill this fucking dog.
Where are you?
She dumbass.
Um...
Anyways.
Well, that's been great, boys.
That's all we were gonna do for tonight.
No, I'm kidding, that's not the case.
Wait, where is it?
What?
Why am I so dumb?
What are you still doing here, Dee?
I'm going the wrong way.
Here's the right way.
Hi, Queen!
I still have any Glover to give you.
Hi, King.
Wait, I need to have it.
Fuck me, brother.
Hold on.
Please, hold.
Yep.
Lay out my arms.
I just, like, hold my arms, though, and he just cuts them off.
Ash of War.
Let's put a little roll in Spark.
Why does it say 14?
I don't understand that.
I could use Storm Stop.
What is Raptor of the Mists?
In the arms of an angel.
So he disarms you, oh my god.
I've smacked your backside for that one.
What does Rolling Sparks do?
Can I boost this while I'm at it?
Okay.
Press Square on it.
BOOM!
I can't.
Why am I so stupid?
Well, listen, I'm very tired.
And I've only drank Baja Blast.
I'm doing my best.
I didn't hold on.
I need to put on the crying.
I'm doing my best.
I'm trying my hardest.
My eyes are burning because I rubbed them after touching spicy food.
You guys still love me?
I already blew out the candle.
Ow.
My hardest is not good enough.
I'm being bullied by my own chat.
And I'm supposed to be the dumb.
Sorry, I was yawning.
I'm not crying. I'm laughing.
But they're hard to distinguish.
My dad was making fun of my laugh the other day.
So my dad hadn't seen my model yet.
And I put on the golf collab.
One, it was really funny because my parents thought I was Emmy.
I was so happy.
And now my dad is laughing at me.
Too.
But then my dad heard me laugh and he was like, never mind.
That's her.
I'm like, how did you know?
You laugh like goofy.
Oh my god, my eyes itch.
I guess I'm when I'm sleepy. I'm just I'm just normal
You do you have a goofy don't tell me I have a goofy laugh
You guys suck I hate you, you know you guys you guys don't love me shut the fuck up
Get away from me
Leave me alone
Turn off stream right now. Don't look at me. Do not perceive me. I'm gonna break stuff
It's all about the he said she said bullshit
Let me break your fucking charity
Hey, I'm you say I have a goofy laugh and then I'm a dork you guys believe me
Oh
My god my eyes were seriously burning though because like I think there was like sauce on my fingers so
Or I just gave myself like I don't know like pink eye from cleaning fia. Although I did wash my hands afterwards, but you never know
What am I doing?
Dip my eyes in milk go wash my face
I don't feel like it
That means I have to get up and I'm very sleepy right now. What am I doing?
What
Why am I
Can I please not be okay, thank you
Then suffer
All right kuma, I'm gonna call you out for a second. Why do you gift?
Why do you gift it up and then you're a great name? I'm gonna cry
How could you do this to me?
You don't even get the emotes for yourself
Because it's funny
Nobody you guys all
You multiple oh, she lovers you all hate me secretly
Don't worry, it's fine
Hey guys people's who treasure he cannot possess where is that from how does that work? I don't know
Oh
You guys I'm just convinced everybody hates me
Because I want attention. I just want attention. So I say everybody
My back hurts um because I'm leaning forward like a fucking crippled infinity were or were I said infinity were
Hi guys, I'm gonna think I'm getting a little dilulu
um
You bet you bet I can run through his legs. Let's do it. I'm gonna thread the needle
I'm gonna go right in between his fire roce
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. I'm threading the needle. I'm gonna thread it
Oh, baby
Uh, it's fine
That counts
I thread it
Like a fine wine. Oh shit
Oh shit
Nailed it needle successfully threaded, you know, it's funny. I could have just fast traveled
Where's the where's the lever
I
Didn't I just TP I'm not gonna toilet paper myself inside
This is a big elevator
Oh
I wonder how the the chain system works. I like I wonder how these elevators work truly
You know, they look very similar to like, you know, because georgia are martin
I wonder if he lended some knowledge to stuff because this reminds me of like the thing on the elevator on the wall
Merica's head is gone. He's like fuck my mother's head
Let's keep taking her car
There's one secret below the elevator
What
I don't believe you there's no secret below the elevator. I already talked to that dude. Uh, I'm gonna
I want to see how these work
I'm gonna remove that
You
Wait
Oh
What
How do I
Guys, how do I
How do
How why can't I
Oh
I was trying to two-handed it was taking me a long time
I
What am I doing
I'm guarding
Where's the ash of war I ordered
Where's the ash of war
I
L2 I am pressing L2
L1 this is L1 I'm flipping a motherfucker off L2
Hold it
I'm holding it
I
That's the ash of war
That's the skill is that it lets me what is it I'm confused
What does rolling sparks do I thought I would roll and it would do sparks
What the f that's fucking stupid I wanted to roll like fucking sonic
Try dual wielding and then L2 what I am already dual wielding
I said you want me to step off the stairs
I don't see no fucking sparks
I don't see no Nicholas sparks up in here
I
Know I can roll like sonic. I thought that was the one that rolls like sonic
Now I have them both out
Why I just punched that fucking
All right, I guess
You
All right, well
Fabulous let's see how this works
Wow
That's great damn I really
I
Really
Sunlocks them I got frostbite proc at least. Oh fuck me brother
Again the music sounds like I'm listening to the used
I didn't think you'd be able to hit me
Ow can I block
Oh, I can't block don't hurt me. No, no, I'm too hot to die. I'm too sexy to die
I only have the perfume of plus two does that mean I have to get more fucking smithing stones, dude
Because I'm literally just gonna fucking end myself
Where's this motherfucker running from come here
I
Get frostbitten bitch
Frostbite frostbite frostbite get it get it frostbite get the frostbite. You're frozen. You're dead
You're losing it
Yeah
I'm dying where the tissues go. I thought I put them next to me. Oh, they're over there
Then I go back to my sword. Well, I'm gonna go back to heal and just reset everything
I have to get up what do you mean I have to get up
Oh
No, I know what you mean again. I'm forgetful
I want to make some babies. I want to get it up
I want to make you honey
And I don't want no trouble
Get it up get it up
I didn't have to get up. I just rolled over in my chair
Get it up
It must be your face
Or it's your body if it ain't your body then it must be your face
Screwing and moderation screwing is such a bore
None of my time is wasted. I do that shit on tour
Oh, yeah
All right
All right, so if I do a little
What the fuck
If I do a little
If I do a little what the fuck I thought
Oh
I didn't have them equipped
Let's go
All right
Yeah, I'm gonna go sit down again
I sound like I'm fucking drunk when I'm just tired
I'm off to see the wizard the wonderful wizard. I'm just gonna up two hand this for a second
I need to sit back. I'm like I have the worst posture right now
I may put up my little
foot rest
If only I was well actually I could play from my couch, but you just hear you just your distant she be the entire time
Yeah, I was literally just shrimping. I normally don't shrimp, but because I'm tired. I can't hold my fucking titties up with my back
No, why are you here? I'm not here
You can't see me
I'm not here. You can't see me. I'm not here. You can't see me
What the where the fuck am I going? Oh what the hell
Uh anyways
Oh, what the I thought I could knock you off
All right, I did
Oh
I just got killed by a fucking soul. Honestly the NPCs in this game are so difficult
They are so much more harder than the base game
Um, just yeah, those guys like the axe guys keep getting me
They got me before when we um
Ever get where we were
In that uh in the catacombs
I
I almost would just beat my head against the microphone
I keep dying in the most stupid way. Yeah, I don't know what that noise was either. That was a gasp
Anyways
It's fine
I came in like a wrecking ball. I never meant so hard enough
All I wanted was to break you
Anyone you wrecked me
The ai's just better
Because I still get them in what was that was like three or four hits
Festive grease. What is the festive grease off?
You scared me
Were you trying to knock me off?
I don't what was going on there. Is anybody else in here?
Just getting up
Do be do be do body
Oh no, sweetie, come back. You know, you're probably just dropping armor. I don't really care that too much
Oh my god, a smithing stone one
Something so far. Oh my god. They gave me the smithing stones. I need it
Wait, okay, sorry
Don't shout. Don't shout. Don't shout. Don't scream be quiet
Oh, fuck. Uh, you guys didn't hear that, right? Can I like
Too bad we need like 15. It's fine. Uh, I'm gonna go for you first
And then well, he's getting back up. I'm gonna fucking run for my life
And try not to die
Oh, no, you don't no, no, I can't get out of the corner
Oh, not the corner. I like his little his uh his
I like you cut G. No, what's it called the twin blades? Yeah
Yeah
He cheated. Yeah, he corner locked me. That's not that's not a fucking sentence. What you guys know what I mean
I don't even know I'm fighting them. I can literally just run past everybody
But again, sometimes I just want to fight people
And see what they drop. So I actually will probably go kill that guy
Although these guys will probably aggro me
and these guys
No, don't knock me off the fucking thing and don't do it
The other guys are gonna come up behind me
No
Nice
What what the fuck
What stop
Stop it
Take that take the smithing stone
um
Anyway, let me just be be be be be be be be be be be
You have a really nice spear
Okay, yeah die there
Oh
Um
Can I let me fix your body there you go now you look a little bit better now. He's just sleeping
He's he's superman
I don't know why that's so funny to me. Hey, let me just
You're sleeping. No, you're sleeping. Oh, sorry to wake you. It's time to die
Okay, maybe I will go after you after you. Oh, I need to crouch
And no you buddy and then I'll just do this and then you'll both get both get hit
You
How does it feel to be cornered, huh?
How how does it feel? Oh black knight armor
Thank you for all the smithing stones. They're what I needed
I'll take that
Mane gush oh main gush
I just get spammed get spammed get spammed all the fucking blood on the wall
Um, I'm covered in blood
I'm just covered in red paint. Jesus Christ. Who got murdered here
Should I go down to that place? Should I have gone down there? Oh, no
Hold on
Don't worry about it. I'm not here. I'm not here. I'm not here. I'm not here. I'm not here. I'm not here
Should I jump down here?
Hurry tell me should I jump down here?
It's back to the start. Okay. Ow. No
Get spammed get spammed get spammed get spammed. Oh, well
Nice
I
Wish
Oh, let me just
Will you get me some uh flasks back?
No no flasks for me. All right
Fuck me then
Heal I just healed what are you fucking talking about?
I'm missing for some reason because I'm not locked on perhaps
Oh, look at that. What's that? I want to look outside. Oh, what's over there?
It's a fucking night
And there's a guy I'll probably loop back around there eventually. I hope there's some more graces in here
All right a fucking feeling you'd be there
There are two of you. There's a guy with fucking
All right, that's probably closed. That's probably the loop around for the grace
Interesting stuff is a bit more further I thought so. All right, let's run
Oh
Sup bitches y'all good. Oh, what's that?
Run run motherfucker run. Oh my god the twin blades
I don't even know where the fuck I am
No, I
Disagree
Oh my who the fuck are you
What's this? Oh fun. Oh, what's this? Oh fun
Is that a fucking sanguine noble who the fuck are you? Yeah back off back off
I'm busy
Ow I'm try this was a trap
I was gonna go right I wanted to um grab that first though
No, I got my fucking nose
Yeah, I love you something act up
Uh we're zooming we're cruising we're coming for air bruising
She's thriving she's whining
She's dying. She's crying. She's rolling. She's tolling. She's dodging
She's holding. She's running. She wants her runes
She's going up and up and up and rolling out of the way
She's rolling and going and jumping
And avoiding some arrows and twin blades. She's going
Over in this direction. I didn't mean to fucking swing
She's going the distance. She's going for speed. Fuck off
She's going in something and something and something and something and time of need
She's going down the stairs. Holy fuck. These are not stairs
Where are all these little short kings doing here? She's getting some grease
She's going to the store and opening it and hoping that they don't hit her
Haha, I'm in an animation and I'm immune. Oh look, what's that?
It's the loop around
Papa squat
What do you mean the summon signs? I've already summoned them from this battle. What are they doing? Ah
Come in here you horse
Come here and I'll frostbite you
Get frostbitten get frostbitten
Oh they look like little monkeys
Get absolutely fucking wrecked bro. Look at you. You look like a little ewok motherfucker
I need to talk to her again
Excuse me. Sorry. It's the Baja. Get in here. I don't want to fucking get gang banged out there
Come here. Come on
Come on king. Come on short king
I
Is a G
I batted him out of the air
Batter up
Oh what the fuck I thought you were dead. I couldn't tell though
Fuck you you literally had like a slew there of health
Run up the stairs
Why do I feel like something should be swooping down on me anytime there's like a steep incline
All right, come on bitches get out. Yeah
We are the brothers three. We look like monkeys. See
Sorry, I'm stealing a game grumps joke because it's one of my favorites
Oh, he fucking canceled me out
Come on. I'm attacking. I'll attack you and I'll attack you next and just spam because it auto locks and it's great
I was worth it. I knew it would be
Rada rada these are cool boats
I like the boats anything stone eight
Holy shit
Silver pickled flower foot foul foot full of a fucking fucking fuck
Hey king, um, I don't really know what you are
But uh, can I frost you?
Can I like unlock hold on I'm looking from side to side. Nope. Okay. There's nothing there. Hey, you are pretty hard like
Pretty. Oh my god. What the fuck is that range?
All right, well
You
What is
Ow
What are you I like your sword can I have it?
I kind of want your sword
Can I have your stuff
Are you serious? You don't fucking drop anything. I want your I want the fit
I want the fit. Give me your give me your fucking clothes
Give me your empty your pockets. Give me your sword. Just give me everything
I drop it sometimes I like it. I also like their magic
Masma oh wait, this is just an elevator
Beep beep beep
I have so many crimson tears left. Uh, you think I can kill them in a three flasks
I think I can oh wait, there's a grace. Oh
Is that what the hell
The spirit
Oh
So I'm in a level what am I doing?
What is this festive
Oh a trace amount of runes and landing attacks. That's pretty neat
Oh, I'm dying slowly
Can you sneeze closer to the mic
Oh
It's like the weapons you get from the dancing lady village uh for like the creepy ones with the god skin apostle
So many but not I'm gonna fucking summon anything. Hey, it's like uh, it's one of this
It's like the ancient spirit except it looks like a horn sent version. What the fuck are you doing?
Holy shit
Fucking teabagger ass just for that. Um
Sorry
Oh you motherfucker, I knew you're gonna show up. Come here. Come here you you little fucking flying monkey motherfucker
Or am what the where the fuck am I
Is there is that another one of them?
I can't I'm stuck
Oh
You're casting that's a cool
Uh
Fucking incantation you got there. That's what I'm thinking
Anything interesting any you guys reading any interesting tomes
What get the sit the fuck down bitch seriously
Yoink, I don't know shadow my little man
I
Can hear one whipping their hair back and forth. Oh what?
Hold on I'm busy. Hold on. I'm hold on. I'm busy. Hold on. I'm I'm busy
I
This guy was a minion short kings come on the first floor storage area and shadow keep what?
Our weapons give you souls when you have enemies
I
Well
Let's go get my shit back then
Oh, please don't even fucking try it love
Hold on bro
What the fuck I didn't go this way last time. That's why I didn't know you were there
Ow
I'm on fire
These don't die
Uh here are my rooms
Uh you why did you fucking miss? Why are you like a black knife assassin, but you're red
You're a red knife assassin
Where am I going? I don't know. This is kind of cool. I like library levels
Very neat very what is it? What how do they say the very demur demur very cool
Good thing I have the fire towels been on otherwise it'd be fucking got uh, there's a lot of you guys here
Can I
Nope, never mind never mind. Uh, never mind never mind. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I was not gonna back stab you
I wasn't I swear to god. I was literally just coming over here to grab this
Blessed bone shard wherever the fuck that is
Uh, then I was turning around and I was going this way. All right. That's that's all I had to say man
I don't mean any trouble
um
Hey
You have a very cool sword
Excuse me
Do you mind getting out of the way? Just do you possibly mind getting out of the way?
Hi miwa
Area was good. It feels really samey to Dark Souls 3. Okay, got you
Yeah, I know there's quite a few like library places in um Dark Souls 3. I believe can I go this way this time?
Oh yoink. Oh
Oh, ow
Oh, no, I can't go this way this time. I need my runes because that's a whole fucking level right there. Ow
So much for I don't know why I fucking healed. I did not need to heal yet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh the pedigral
Oh, what's down there hold on
Yeah, yeah. Oh, what's over here?
Fire coil. Why is everybody throwing? Why do are they using fire? Oh, well actually I was gonna say
Why would they use fire in the library? But they're stones. So I guess it doesn't matter
Okay, then I walk past this guy. No, sorry. Excuse me. Um
Stop. Oh, I'm in the corner. Oh
You spin me right around baby right around like a record baby right around round round
Oh my god, what the fucking hell? I'm in the corner. Oh, no, hold fucking shit
Help
I was trying to find that does anybody know where the stairs are
Hello, I'm stuck again
Can you I don't want to lose my runes. Um
Can you guys direct me to the nearest stairway? Thank you
No, you just want to throw flames at me instead
understandable
Um, I'm just gonna heal. Oh fuck. Oh shit
Oh my god. Okay. I'm gonna have to start killing some of you. No, you're gonna kill me first. Oh, please
I don't want to
I don't want it
Can I just sit down?
Go away
Oh
Did I get I know just sitting down fuck up my runes. I don't really care that much to be honest with you
Why can't I find
The stairs
I
Thought they're over there, I guess they're not you're right walking around is a lot easier
Where the fuck are the stairs?
Oh
No, not that way because there's just that dude. Can you
Fucking stop
I'm
Literally letting you live with your lives and you're
You're gonna kill me. You're gonna kill me. You're gonna kill me. No, you're not. No, I forbid it. I forbid it. I forbid I forbid it
Stop auto walking. Oh here it is
La la la
I'm just gonna where are they up here
Can this poison go away
All right, let me just hi
Okay, thank you. I appreciate your you're really sweet
Oh
I can't
I'm on fire. I'm poisoned and I'm on fire and there's probably I'm gonna grab this and somebody's probably gonna fucking shoot me
Oh, yep, it's you. It's you. You're the you're the bitch
You know guys, I think I hate this area. I take it back. I think I think I hate it. I take it back
You guys are gonna destroy all the important tomes
Anyways, let me look at the chat
I don't even know do I even have enough
What did I want to put it put it into intelligence or dex did you guys say should I put it into the strength? I don't know
I
Was back is on the first floor here. I do want to talk to him because I know he has some interesting lore stuff to say
Good night your eepiness has peaked. Oh have a good eep
Have the best eep
My nose is killing me
I can't just go to 60 intelligent, but I don't even have like
I don't even have like
sorceries
Like I haven't run into any sorceries in the dlc
Like what's up with that? Are there no sorceries in the dlc?
I feel like this is incantations
And
Mpc is a good chunk of them
Are you familiar with how level caps and soft caps work in this game? Yeah, I think it was soft caps
Intelligence at like 70
Invigorate 60. Isn't that the case? I don't fucking know
I
Endurance in mid
Are you saying I'm mid? Oh, what the hell would I just knock over?
There are very few sorceries, but most are boss powers like remembrances
Lightning rim. Oh, that's right. That's what it's called. No
For weapon damage soft caps at 45 oh
Oh soft caps at 80. I thought it was 70
Okay
Let's just do intelligence. Although I kind of want strength so I can weird wield those fucking
Um
Well, I can always just respect it doesn't really matter because I want to be able to read wield Rinaldo's sword
That's Rilana's swords at some point
All right, now I don't have to worry about these fucking
Oh
It's down here besides a dead man
It's just a Denver
Oh my god, please just you guys need to relax like
Live a little or something. Why is that there's no stairs there? Why is that guy just okay? You need to sit down stop
Take a step back breathe. Oh, you have a lot of money. So I'm gonna kill you
Sorry, you give extra
Yeah, you too. I'm
I'm not lucky. I've accidentally clicking the non lock-on button
It's probably a hundred like I probably get another level killing everybody in this place
Stop
It I'm gonna keep spamming you because you're too short and I can't see
past my tears
From my oh fuck off
You missed motherfucker where's on spot?
Oh, he's not even aggroed
Will he get poisoned that would be funny
All right. Well sick
Stop
It's like I'm fighting an annoying child
Okay, you said Anzbach is on the first floor
Let's take a look see poo around
That's just
You can't hear me right if I crouch behind you you guys get easily
Oh, I can't do the timing for that. I don't want to have to fight all of you
I'll go up here
This is where it's safe
It's funny I wanted like I wanted like a faith int build when I first did this and now I'm just like fully in
Do you have anything important up here?
No, oh, there's a long
Long road. Oh, can I jump on the feet?
Why are you so far away and I can't hit you
I'm gonna get poisoned in a second. Oh, I'm on the feet. Haha. I'm on the beat. Oh my god. I'm on his ass
No
Go away
I'm busy climbing up a horn scent. Oh, don't mind if I do
Don't mind if I do
What is he just scarring here your arm? He just fucking cuts off his arm and leaves it there
Well, I know I passed him but I got distracted by the grace. What do you expect?
Wait, can I level up my scottish scabba?
I can't okay. Well, fuck you then. Um, oh, it's interesting
You know, I'm wondering I'm interested in the uh, is this an actual body or is it like a statue?
It looks like it's an actual body
You think it has an actual dingaling
And then yeah, then you have
I don't know man because this looks and it's it's interesting that they hang them up and they do the rune of
I
Don't know man because this looks and it's look it's interesting that they hang them up and they do the rune of
They do the Elden Ring
rune or America's rune
not well
I don't think that worked out for me
Um, can you jump back on his head? I like it I should have been able to make that
I feel like I should be able to jump back on his head
I well
Oh my god
Well now I'm determined to try
You know what would be an interesting way to try let's do it like let's try this
Let's try this
I'm gonna jump up
and then
I press the button to do
my
To do my special and it didn't do it because I wanted to use my um
I wanted to try to do that to jump over
But it didn't work
See I was trying a big brain it guys all right
You know what what if I jump on this desk and then I run and jump
I was pretty close that time
I ran and jumped
What are you talking about? I'll do it again. I'll I'll demonstrate for your small
puny man brain
You ready?
Look at this excellence. I'm a
I'm a I'm a
Pro elden ring player see that
Yeah, now I'm dancing on his ass
Torquen on his ass. Okay. Where is ansbach?
There's a lot in here that I missed
What the fuck?
Jesus christ. How is anybody supposed to move through this place?
It's clear that I should also be able to I feel like I should be able to be in like goat
Its legs are gone. That's kind of fucked up
Where's uh
Yeah, but yeah, oh
It's like armpits or back of the legs sensual. Oh, what's I wonder if anybody has edited the clothes off of this
Ha bitch you miss
Try again
Oh
Can I drop down there probably not I'm not that skilled
You guys gonna keep spamming me with poison I don't want to walk over there until you're done
Ow
Oh my god, there's like 50 of you
And then get poisoned
Yeah
Do I have any of the staunching boluses? Oh, I fucking smacked him back. Oh
Interesting
Cool, um
Oh, can you
I'm not here
No, I hear him walking towards me
Okay
I guess I'll just be poisoned. I look like I'm just stinky
Stop
Don't try it
Oh, what telepart explore
I explore that would mean explore the area with the bookshelves. I've already explored
All the books. Oh, no, I haven't I think there was like a whole side I missed
Hi, how's it going? I'm just gonna kill you all before you kill me. I'm so sorry
I don't know what's happening here
What's that beast horn fascinating I'm still stinky
I thought you said the first floor
Isn't this the first floor
You sons of bitches lied to me
How could you hold on I'm poking around
No, can you stop
Can we just can we just stop the madness?
Can we stop the sadness?
So smithing stone
Thanks. Oh look at this. I can just walk on down and then I can pop a squat
Right here
This is not the first floor this is this is the ground floor then you have the first floor and then the second floor
This is not the first floor. This is the ground for us the bottom floor
This is not the first floor
Unless you consider like from here to here then okay, then I would understand
Yes, in America the ground floor is the first is the first floor. That's what we call it the ground floor
um
Come on out. Can I jump up there and just like completely just fucking get you?
Oh my god
Well, am I getting an allergy attack?
Okay, so Anzac is on this floor guys. You don't have to try to school me on what floor it is. I generally don't care
I don't care if you call it the fucking nymph floor
I just need you to explain it in dumb terms for me
It's the lobby
Okay, Anzac is that no
Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you
What you want some you want some you want he wants some he wants it he's getting it
First section
Is he over here?
Nope
All right, well I would came from there. I didn't really explore this way
So I will
Go over here Anzac are you over here?
Excuse me, sir. Why is it so fucking dark? This is just a fucking corner
What the fuck where am I?
Hello
Oh, oh, thank you
I'm sorry. I'm sorry
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. I apologize. I'm so sorry
It's a dead end. Oh, yeah, just kidding. You're right. Wait, why is this like
Why is this bookshelf fake? It's a fake fucking bookshelf
Oh my god, I can't breathe. I have to breathe out my mouth. There's a lever. Oh
I see I'm finding fucking secrets, bro. You see this shit. Oh shit. This is where uh, yeah, that's cool
Nice
Oh my god, stop I can't breathe
You said he's he's uh, total opposite of the grace. I was waiting for this man to assault me
Come up come closer. He's moving at a slow pace to come beat my ass
You know what he's actually not he's not you're not too bad old man
Oh, nope. He's posted up now. Stop stop. We were friends and then you ruined it
Why do you have to do that?
We were having a good time
So in the area where that flame night was like there was like oh, but there was like three places where one was working
What are you talking about?
There was like a bunch
You mean in the corner over here, sorry
Stop it
Oh, it's over here
Ooh, something's gonna jump out at me. Oh, no
Nothing
Nobody's gonna fucking try to assault me
It's all right nice sick
We love to see it
What he's living in the corner, what do you mean? I don't see him
Hello
How the fuck am I supposed to see this guy? He literally blends in
He blends in
No way I guys I have explained to you. I can't see in games
Why don't you understand? I can't see in games
Hi
It's been like two days
Yeah
Here I am
I don't even know why I'm talking to you. It looks like a rock
Dynastic
Yeah, because his fucking ass turned
I almost said radigan. It's turned to run on to him used him and to run on
Excuse me
You know what's interesting to me is that Ronnie and Micola are honestly a lot more alike
And then you'd think
Like micola is a shit person
Honestly, Ronnie is too because she takes she took squad wins soul
I mean bought body killed his soul and killed her body so she can you know separate herself from her two fingers
And but like and he was a good. He's a pretty good dude. It seemed
And this left him a fucked up husk and made like death root and stuff
and Micola
This goes ahead and uses the same method
Except he uses it a mogwin
Not mogwin mog and just takes his body for his own purposes
Yeah, Ronnie was way more
Direct
Somebody clip this
I couldn't see him. What do you tell if I'm running around you don't even fucking see him
I also didn't remember what he looked like
Okay, like can I
What am I doing? Wait, let me see if I exhausted all of his dialogue
Hey
Yeah, you know what they did with this body they turned it into another person against there that persons will
Because we don't know if Radon wanted to be a part of that vow
Because it's funny because it's because like Micola liked I feel like Micola wanted Godwin to be his a consort first
But then he made had Radon do it
Because then he just became obsessed with Radon unhealthily
I fell asleep in my chair in a minute go to sleep go to bed
I
Have no idea what's going on. Well, I only like I just like listening to stuff about like I like watching video essays about the lore
But I don't literally I don't go out of my way to like
Usually talk to NPCs and like actually figure out what the fuck they're saying and piece stuff together. I usually don't care about that
um
Okay, where is the stair
Or fuck
Where's this elevator? Oh my god, please
What is the where does the elevator lead to
This is not the elevator. Oh
Don't do it. Oh, you did it. You did it. Look what I had to do. Look what I had to do
Young child obsessed being not like his mom but ends up like his mom and even worse like
I I generally like I was very interested in Micola's character in the base game because I was like
I was really wondering what his association with st. Trina was and everything and then like oh, these are the same people
And just like figuring out how the same they're the same people and stuff. Um, what are you fucking waiting for?
Smother fucker, um
I fucking kicked this little man. Um
Another area I can explore
What do you mean? Is there stuff that's like worth it there? Or is it like a fucking rota fruit?
Rota leaf
Down the lift
Where's the lift
I won't lie to you. I don't know how I missed this room before
Oh
Uh
Go
More another ash for the perfume why damn this is a fucking fast elevator. I'm getting dizzy
Jesus christmas
Hello, is anybody gonna fucking attack me? There's a jar person. That's uh, no, it's not. Whoa. Why is this place so fucking big?
Oh my god. Yeah, that's great. That's that's absolutely lovely. Um, anyways
Stop it
I should have fucking knew it there's always there's always there always I didn't mean to press that
They're always gonna find a way to jump scare you. Oh, look at the little jar people
I look like they're having a lot of fun
This is a better ash
I kind of want to jump down and like just lay down that fucking guy, but I'm not going to uh, because I'll probably just
Eat shit
Let's go
The fourth floor
I
Do it no balls
Like I honestly just want to get to mesmer this is all like but don't tell me how
This is pretty
Kind of want to jump off damn this is genuinely like a really
I hear bird. What is that? Oh, it's a bat
This is generally this is a really fucking huge castle and it's really amazing level design
You're gonna come get me a little bat. You're just gonna be up there
Like I'll probably do some more exploring off stream, but
But
What the hell
Why are you doing fucking
Faith shit at me now. Um
Can I please just like come up here and explore the area for like five seconds?
I'm sneezing I can't do this
Oh
I almost rolled off can you fall off that would be fucking great. I'm really crying tears
Stop you're gonna kill me. Oh
How am I still alive that doesn't make any sense I should have died a long time ago
Oh, okay, that's not very nice
Oh
Oh, that was pretty neat
Oh, I'm still getting up. How's your stance not broken?
Am I gonna have to spam on you? I'm stuck
It doesn't matter though because you're dead. I wish you'd drop your fucking sword her whatever the hell
I think I have enough health
What's gonna fucking jump out? Oh, yeah some bats. Oh, it's down here
Oh my god, chill out. This is some dudes. Oh, okay
It's pretty neat
Mesmer really I wonder why what the significance is for mesmer to have all these. Um
Oh, yes, I think that that scroll is actually like an important plot point. Um
To have all these tomes and then like he has like paper and he has stone
Very interesting to me
Like why why why did he collect so many books, you know, but you guys all fucking looking at there's nothing there
I guess I'll just leave you alone
They're literally what are you guys staring at usually sometimes when they have dudes like staring at like mean something
Yeah, that's right. It's on box quest. That's why
All right, coming here you stupid fucking bat. I don't even know how your friends like followed me
Uh, sorry, I was just scared that I was gonna clip through the
I was gonna clip through the damn
No wall
What you doing EEN? That's cute. Oh, there's another one. There's another one
Oh
Oh, I didn't think you would hit me. I don't know why I can't tell the depth of what's happening right now
Okay, I wonder what these ember mesmers probably to make a mesmer fire grease or something
Hi, you're probably gonna try to kill me so I'm gonna kill you first. I'm so sorry
I'm just fucking through him. Jesus. You too
That was kind of a delayed reaction. Uh, I can't see
Not again
You're gonna kill me
Let's just just stop. I only have one flask left bro. It's my last flask
Bitch
Huh
Yeah
Is she above me? Bitch can't read for some reason
There's a grease up one more flight. I assumed as much because I hear Freya nearby. Yeah
What the fuck are you looking at looks like I push you to the fire
You're stepping on stuff
He's literally downstairs. I don't know what to tell you
Alrighty oh, that's a way to take the stairs I suppose
Sorry, I meant to be sneaky. Yeah, what's a spirit calculus? I've never heard of that
Fascinating. Oh, I was debating whether which way to go but since you walked by
You were over here
I'll go this way
Oh, this is a dead end. Can you stop spinning?
Oh
Hey Freya you want to help me?
That's a fucking fire
Am I in the shadow realm? No, I don't know what you're talking about
What the hell I can already tell that there's so many places to go in this fucking place. What?
How where what are you doing? Why are you just running at me?
I'm trying not to fall off
How did you I actually hit b before our r1 before you could do anything so that's extremely confusing to me
Freya is indifferent to my suffering
Okay, it's getting a lot harder to get through
The shadow keep that I thought it was I thought it was gonna be pretty straightforward
I thought it was gonna be like, um, you fucking just stop
Oh
My god, brother, they are pretty tanky and fast. That's very
Sick outfit. I kind of remind me of Renault with her little stupid fucking hats
You enter from two different directions, that's pretty that's very interesting
All right, let me grab my roots
And I'll kill you how about that? Oh, oh, I'm pressing b but you have me stun locked
What the hell bro? I hate you
I
Could only imagine what the damage is with without the talisman that I have on
They're not even tough
Like I'm leveled enough that it's not really super tough. It's just like I'm just not really playing properly
Oh
You're gonna get me again. Oh my god
It's like I'm someone who I just I like I'm not really like
Perceptive or strategic with my roles like I'll watch some eldering players and they know the moves that
I
Very well and like if I paid closer attention, then I would probably fare better but because
Because if I am how the way I am I should not have given you the high ground Anakin
Stop just stop you're ridiculous. Oh my god, you're so angry
No, don't come over here
Can I knock you off are you gonna keep spinning?
You're my z
Oh pretty deep off because I'm ebh3am
What am I doing? What am I doing tomorrow today?
technically
What am I what's my stream?
What am I doing?
What am I streaming today?
I don't even know
Borderlands too, okay, but what's that time is that at four? I don't fucking know that you walk downstairs sweet
What
There's a whole place I should totally just drop down. Oh
Stop
I just want to steal your shit
There's tons of dead bodies everywhere that you guys don't bother to clean the fuck up. So I'm gonna do it for you
There's a lever
What is this for
What the hell
Stop creeping at me
fucking weirdo
fucking
pervert
What the fuck
What the fuck am I looking at here?
Oh my god
It's pretty cool. Oh, it's actually really fucking sick. I'm just impressed
I
I've never played Borderlands before I picked FPS's except for Titanfall that I haven't really played before like I've never played
Fallout New Vegas and ever I don't know Fallout New Vegas really isn't an FPS to me. It's mostly just a
RPG
It's fun though. Hi. How are you guys doing?
By my lord makes it who is she is that Freya?
Oh it is
Um, I'm gonna pop a squat real quick
No, you you'll be surprised I'll wake up at 7 or 8 a.m. Tomorrow because my body just automatically wakes me up super early
Um, sometimes I'm awake, but I just don't tweet yet because I'm just like I'm still like doing stuff
Like I'm still waking up and taking care of the babies
um
But yeah nine times eight eight times out of ten I wake up at literally like
Seven oh fucking fuck bro
Oh my god
I just
I just literally hate him
How did you get down here so fast?
What is up with the tracking?
That's ridiculous the AI for that particular
Stop oh that actually thank you. Thank you so much
Thanks
Ow, it's fine
Oh, this is pretty cool. Look at it. It's uh, am I supposed to jump?
Well, actually technically I can just walk. Oh, oh, please calm down
Um, what are you doing you motherfucker? You're all just standing
Oh my god, I almost missed that jump um
Hello
Why is there a stake america here?
Why is there a stake america here? Are you secretly like a super crazy boss? No
I was a fucking bat doing what the bat doing
I'm pretty sure that's where I came from before at some point. Yeah
At least there's only just fucking ghouls up here the ghouls are really easy to fight
Well
Hi, don't mind me. Just grabbing a number of mesmer
This is the boss room. Why are you in front of it?
Ow fray a shut up
Oh
You are absolutely insane
A frostbite proc is hard to get
I do like
Um, ralana's armor. Well, thank god for all that. Sorry fucking wrong way. Sir. Excuse me, sir
Excuse me. No
Fuck me. I just it's not nice of you. I'm I would spare you both if you would just let me
If you would just let me
Ah
Oh
That's a really fucking cool sword. I was trying to dodge that when I was in my drinking animation
Oh Jesus
He's like two completed this game. I'm about to burn to death. Oh my god
Why am I not getting any blood proc on you just fall off motherfucker
I realized oh cool. Nice. Oh flames beer. I like it
It was funny because in my head immediately when I fell off
what started playing
was
Oh fuck. I did side agrees. Um
Um
Just like I see fire just started playing in my head and if I let me all burn together
Inside
Wait
I see if I
First you have money that I want. Give me your fucking money
Why are they they have a lot of um, I almost fucking miss that they have a lot of rooms
I'm surprised something like a little ghoul has that many rooms
He
Please don't fall
Okay
What is this animal I'm crawling on I can't really tell to be honest with you
Shut up for you
Will you who knows who knows if you ever will
Stop I didn't mean to do that, but that actually worked out. What the hell are you healing? That's too bad
They're dead
I'm surprised they're gone
I don't want to lose all my rooms
What is this
No
I
Is it grace ahead
I'm trusting you
Oh
I believe there's a lot of scotty tree fragments in here
I
Can I level I don't think I can
Okay, okay
I thought I had three I think I only have two fuck
I
Hello, who's in here?
Skibbity tree wait, is this mesmer?
What
Why the fuck am I walking like this?
Oh my god, I'm anxious
Damn you're really calling out my mixed race like that
Why is your voice hot
There was like an edit of mesmer as like a daddy and I'm like bet
Although his limbs are pretty long although all the proportions in this game are fucked
I'm gonna cover your eye
You are your mother's son
Oh beam
Geez that's definitely an erupting opening. I don't really know your moveset at all
I like I've seen gameplay of people fighting you
Oh
Ah how am I alive?
Thank you for letting me heal that was pretty kind of you
I heard mesmer is pretty weak. Oh, I should dodge to the side for that definitely impaling me bro
Well
Mesmer's not mesmer's mesmer's he's a fucking sneaky poo
There's a summon. Yeah, I don't care. I'm doing it myself. I'll do a summon later
I like to see what their moveset is
Oh, I should probably not be as close to you. You're really, you know, you're kind of tall
Oh, interesting
I love this. How does this make you feel? Okay, you can get out of it. That's nice. I have literally too hell
Uh
For some reason
He has a really cool moveset I like it I like the little sneaky poos
He's cute sneaky poos
Yeah, because I like I like to like try them by myself a cup only a little bit like, uh, I
I feel like
Um
Why are you oh
I'm getting the same feels that I felt with one of the lies of p characters when you're fighting the king of the puppets
I'm like, oh, oh
Little twinks coming after me
Don't worry, I'm not gonna beat him like this. Don't you think I'm gonna beat him by myself. I'm gonna try
Not that it's gonna happen
I just want to see the type of damage I can do let's let's do a little
Little sparkly
Oh, I thought I definitely rolled farther enough away
Get frosted bitch get frosted
Get frosted get frosted get frosted
Ow
Oh
What's happening here
Oh, oh, oh, oh stop
I'm trying to fucking get away from you and you're just get frosted get frosted get frosted
Get frosted
Damn, okay, I might level up
I'll accidentally get up three at a time I'll log off I'll like end stream
I'll be like all let me try one more time and then I fucking kill them
I kind of killed R'nala and three try R'alana and three tries off stream. Um, let me
Um
Why I'm literally brain dead right now, uh
I'll see that
It's because I just I don't I think I do this lock in better when I'm um
Off stream and sitting on my couch
I'm going the wrong fucking way. That's how tired I am
Although no, if I was if I was awake, I would
Where am I?
I would also be going the wrong way. What was this door always open. Oh, that's Fia's room. What the fuck?
I'm so out of it
Hi, um
I don't have any money I'll suck your horn
Oh
I was I was here like five seconds ago
Okay
He needed that
Whatever that is
I'm changing the ash of war
I'm about to become the perfume master
Okay, I'm gonna do like a couple more attempts and then I'm gonna go to bed because I am delirious
I
Nine I do the bells off stream. What do you mean the bells?
Let's try it queen. What are you doing?
Okay, I should probably jump to the side instead of backwards for that
How did you hit me?
Oh like that
He is a fun fight because
Why is my hitbox so small?
He's very
It's very interesting move set, but it's not too difficult. It is definitely like an entertaining move set like it is it
Like it's it's challenging, but it's not frustrating, you know
It's all it's all about timing
That I don't have
You
Why am I getting hit by that suddenly when I was able to dodge it before
Get frosted I'm not locked on you get frosted
Get frosted I'm gonna die
Oh
Yeah messmer messmer
Wow, he was really born in
Malate my maricob is like, you know what I'm gonna give you the most snake fucking sounding name besides
With all fucking asses in it
Um, honestly, I bet I could beat him with the ash
Let's see
Who are you? What do you who are you doing boy?
Because if I like just fucking yeah, yeah, yeah
I forgot to heal
Actually, maybe not because I was hoping if I actually just give just the come back here
Oh my god, I'm getting caught up in the crossfire
Can you please get frosted in I don't
Quite under whoa
That was the oh my god
Definitely just got wet from that
Holy shit, that was fire get it
Dodge forward into him. Yeah, it seemed like that was the thing to do. Okay, so maybe
Maybe
It isn't
Like
It's definitely not that easy
Hiking
Ow, why did I roll that close no help actually, what are you gonna do? Oh my god
See that's what I wanted you to do and you weren't doing that before you fucking Jesus Christ, it's kind of cool to watch
Like literally I'm pretty sure this is like the king of puppets fight in lines of p
Does he does the same thing? He throws you up and he impales you on like a spear and I remember playing and being like
I grabbed does hurt like hell
Um, no, it's I'm not it's mostly me like fangirling over how awesome that the fight is choreographed
To be honest with you
Oh
No, I went too early. Thank you for letting me get up
No
It's really it's all it's literally I need to do my timing better
I think I'm just are you is he waiting leopard print? What the fuck is that?
I know it's snake skin. I was very confused for a second
I don't really think it has to do with leveling maybe you know, I could probably get some more scabbadabba to do but as fragments, but
I might do that. I might get some more scatter tree fragments and come back to it later
I
Wonder if you can like repost him and he are like, can you backstab him? I don't know
What's his poise like?
like
I don't know
Ow
Damn, so please don't
I
Comes like in the process of standing up. I kind of do anything. Oh, they have a little way. I didn't notice he has like little fucked up wings
You know, I was literally I would do this
You know, what was it? Oh, no as when I was two-handing I would do that
And it literally knocked down ralana
Uh after two hits of doing this
So I'm wondering if I do that for him if it will
Stagger him as much as did ralana
So we'll see
I jumped way too fucking early
Oh, my timing is all off. I'm gonna see if it works. Nope
Oh
Okay
All right
Nice
Thank you
Oh you fucking bitch
I can't get close enough to him
He is
Some wide range
Damn, I'm already dead brother
He's a lanky motherfucker
So if I I never block
I never parry. Uh, I parried a fucking lot and uh
Lies a pee because you have to
You
Wait, can I can I please get up dude? I just want to practice parrying you
No, I can't parry a grab
We'll see we'll see
I need a tear from the golem
Yeah, I never really I never parried any time I played Elden Ring
I only parried when I like if I was playing like what like Bloodborne I'd probably do it
Um, but otherwise
Ow
Yeah
Yeah, I can't I don't think I can parry him
Well, yeah, I might have to get more scabbadabadabada fragments. I literally just want to practice parrying him. That's all I want to do
All right, I'm not gonna even
Okay
Oh, I got him once
I got him once but I don't
What is the parry tier two I don't
Is it improve your parrying? I don't know how it does that because that's all again. I bet it's funny
Out um
I was very like I'm pretty okay at parrying
Thank you
No, no, how did you fuck you bro?
No
Yeah
I thought he was gonna throw me off the map
That would have been sick actually if you just fucking chucked me off of the arena. This is a nice arena. I like it
Pretty nifty Bloodborne and Sakura was built for parrying but I never felt parrying as primary K
It's really not though
It's really not um
I actually prefer parrying I like the timing of it
I'm still sitting down
Oh, I can't parry that
Oh
Okay, I give the fuck up. I definitely can't parry him
I I don't have the timing right to attempt to parry him if I could dodge
If I can't dodge because I don't have the timing right. I'm not going to be able to parry
Dodge we sink it at mitigation. I understand. Um
I'm gonna end it here because it's almost 4 a.m
And I'm quite tired, but we will probably I might do some when I wake up. It depends. Um, I might do some
just like looking for
Golden seeds and more uh scottotree fragments
I might do that sort of farming off stream
Um, and then I'll try to go for maybe I'll we'll just I might not go to mesmer right away. Maybe I'll like
Scoot scoot about and look at other people look at other um
Little mini bosses like I know I could probably fight like the other guy that rides the hippo
Maybe I sucked with the hippo. So who knows?
The excuse me
Look for bell bearings. Uh, yeah, I have to get the bell bearings too. That's a good point
Um, I might not do a gorilla elden ring for a little bit
I'm probably just gonna work on like the next couple days just like farming stuff
Um, so I could set up for the next
Stream and everything um, but yeah, I hope that you guys had like a fun time hanging out with me for a little bit
I apologize um for the stuff with my cat, but you know, when you gotta go you gotta go
Um
But I hope you guys have a good rest of your night or day or evening or morning
I kind of like
like late night stream like this because um, I feel like the chat's nice and slow and I can kind of
Interact with you guys better
No, the cat's okay
Um, my throat is starting to itch and my nose is totally blocked and I've been breathing through my mouth
I'm probably going to snore because obviously when my nose is blocked my mouth opens
I still have a taco to eat but I can't eat it
Someone's that stick it in the fridge and have a taco for breakfast
Maybe
So far my tummy is fine
I kind of I can't really tell if it hurts a little maybe because I haven't been focusing on it
Maybe I just need a fart. Who knows?
um
Blackface taco
Um, but I hope you guys sleep well if you've been up staying up with me. Otherwise, I hope you have a rest of your day
I hope whatever you're working on if you're at work or if you're doing something in the background or if you have me in the background
You're just listening to me. I hope
That you can complete it
And thank you to all the lurkers
um
for just hanging out even you know
super late and um
Thank you also, uh for
Coming to the roleplay stream earlier. So I appreciate that. I know it was short. Um
We intended to have it be like a little short thing just a little funny skit and hang out
Um, I'm gonna care about you all. I hope that you are doing well
I hope that you had a good day
um
yeah
My day was good because I got to meet old friends and
I'm not meet old friends. I got to see old friends and then I got to meet new ones
Like I'm very much looking forward to my collab on monday with um some peeps. So with emmy
Um
So sweet dreams dream of me
I won't call you stinky because I've been stinky because I was walking around with poison being a stinky girl
Members is still on monday. Yes, it'll be after the chain together stream
um
We're gonna watch scary movie. I have some popcorn. There's some kettle corn. So grab some popcorn
Grab some snacks. Um, I'll spend some time
I might break you on audio with Azura. Oh, sorry. I remember I sent it to her because she was like, can I see your half?
Because I don't know how to do this. I'll make sure
Um, so I haven't listened to it. So I hope that you guys enjoy
You know I love laughter
Yeah, we just wanted to make people laugh and just be a little silly because we like um
Neanna was just like I want to do one of those like meme role plays people do like
Like that one's like your girlfriend accidentally like fucking kills you or whatever
Like those like silly ones
Um
Yeah, you're only stinky because I can't smell you. So you could be stinky. Yeah, gf crashes the car
Um, but I just can't smell right now because I can can't breathe
Um
Showing your stink. Uh, well, I hope you guys have a good night. Um, let me see. I'm literally just gonna probably throw you into someone's chat
We'll see
I don't know who's up this late probably some of my people on either side of the world
Uh, well, I'm gonna send you to scarle, but you guys don't have to have a raid message
You guys can just sneak in if you want to
Um, because scarla is the only person that's streaming up this late right now that I can raid
So I didn't want them
In the view so yeah, I can't talk you guys know what I'm saying. Um, but I have a good night
Um, so probably
It'll be funny if she says my name on the gun
All right, bye guys later. Have a good one